mary lyon used the drug primidos as a
pregnancy test in the 1970s and her
daughter was born with a shortened arm
ever since she's been a woman on a
mission along with husband mike
to prove the link between the drug and
the damage to her daughter
as well as malformations to hundreds of
other babies whose mothers used the drug
earlier this year an independent review
in the uk found primidos caused
avoidable harm
and should have been taken off the
market 10 years before it was
but germany is where the drug was
manufactured
until now there's been little enthusiasm
here to explore its potential dangers
and so mary went with sky news to berlin
last year to meet
german mps i feel quite quite hopeful
and i'm very hopeful now that we are in
germany
that the german government may hopefully
get behind the german victims
inside the bundestag we spoke to mps
about primidos which was called doyganon
in germany
does angela merkel know about this i
don't know
i don't think so she doesn't know
she doesn't think no not this meeting
but does she know about doygano
if you said deugen on to angela merkel
she knows you should ask
i will ask
i will try it it can't be that people
who have very many disabilities
from medicament that they
are from a medicine trauma product that
they
stand alone and have no help from the
government
and not from politics in this meeting a
recent study from professors at oxford
university was presented and afterwards
german mps wrote to their health
minister and now
the government here has said there will
be a review in germany
similar to the one in the uk looking at
whether this drug should have been
removed from the market earlier
i do know what it's like to get mps to
attend a two-hour meeting it's not easy
but they were superb campaigners in
germany have been relying on
developments in the uk
to nudge their calls forwards we wait
for
for england because we have not so so
many support in germany it was very
difficult for us
that support is growing the drug was
made by shearing now owned by
pharmaceutical giant bayer
the uk review team believed that bayer
has a moral obligation to offer
financial help to the victims of
primitives
but bayer says there isn't sufficient
evidence of a causal link between the
drug
and malformations the review under the
german government
will give its opinion in the summer of
next year
jason farrell sky news